anlage ganz im süden der algarve ganz im
süden portugals er vermisstenfall
madeleine mccann ist bis heute noch
nicht gelöst wenn so eine große lage wie
ein deutscher verdächtiger im fall
maddie mccann passiert dann kann man
ganz gut erleben wie dieser supertanker
bild anfängt zu stampfen
da dort deutschland die crime doku von
bilden
mein name ist sky dumont und ich begrüße
euch zum zweiten teil unserer
doppelfolge zu einem der berühmtesten
kriminalfälle unserer zeit
wir sind dem möglichen täter dicht auf
den fersen denn es gibt seit 2020 neue
entwicklungen im fall die entführung von
maddie mccann
43 jährige der derzeit in haft sitzt der
vorhin von bild reporter kai feldhaus
genannte medien tanker bild zeitung
kommt in bewegung als christian b wegen
eines sexualverbrechens dass er in
ottokar begangen hat festgenommen wird
später wird das schuldig gesprochen und
sitzt seitdem eine haftstrafe in
deutschland ab
kai feldhaus ist nach portugal gereist
um den spuren im fall der seit 2007
vermissten maddie mccann nachzugehen das
mädchen gab es fünf jahre alt wäre heute
eine 20 jahre junge frau und hätte sich
vermutlich schon gemeldet würde sie noch
leben das scheint aber tragischerweise
nicht der fall und medi eine gewalttat
zum opfer gefallen zu sein
das hier ist das gerichtsgebäude von
portimao und auf unserer zeitreise durch
das leben von christian w sind ja ein
punkt angekommen wo seine kriminelle
karriere in portugal einen ersten
dämpfer erhält
er ist nämlich hier in diesem gericht
2006 zu acht monaten haft verurteilt
worden gemeinsam mit seinem kompagnon
michael de sind die beiden verknackt
worden weil sie diesel und solarpaneele
geklaut haben dabei erwischt worden sind
die sie eigentlich für kleines geld
verhökert haben und damit ihr leben zu
finanzieren
christian b ist dann mit michael
gemeinsam eingefahren das haben zwei
weitere freunde aus dieser kleinen
kriminellen clique ausgenutzt um in das
haus von christian b einzusteigen und
dort wertsachen zu klauen und das ist
insofern ein für den weiteren verlauf
extrem wichtigen moment
als dass diese beiden freunde man cds
und helge b die bei ihm eingebrochen
sind auch eine videokamera mit kassetten
geklaut haben und auch diesen kassetten
behaupten die beiden freunde des
verdächtigen seien vergewaltigung sehen
gewesen wie christian b verschiedene
frauen vergewaltigt aus diesen
ermittlungen heraus ist dann dieser
haftstrafen erwachsen die jetzt gerade
verbüßt in deutschland
wir wollen direkte weiterschalten zu
thomas knoop nach kiel dort sitzt der
tatverdächtige christian w 1 also
erscheint im regal berufskriminelle zu
sein schwerpunkte liegen allerdings
immer bei sexualstraftaten drogenhandel
und einbruchsdiebstahl erscheint also
richtig sei nicht unterhalten ab der
einen seite mit bestritten zu haben und
auf der anderen seite immer wieder auch
die 6
christian b war also schon immer
auffällig und führte lange zeit ein
leben im schattigen reich der
kriminalität
[Musik]
aber wie es christian b in die fänge der
portugiesischen polizei gelangt um das
zu ergründen trifft reporter kai
feldhaus gleichen der umgebung von
breyer gelost elia sie ist die mutter
eines mädchens das von christian b
sexuell belästigt wurde des portugiesen
sie wirkt aufgeschlossen und dennoch
nervös als sie ein foto von christian b
sieht das der reporter ihr zeigt
können sie einmal beschreiben was das
für die situation war als du diesen mann
die der musik der stadt für seine
vorstellungen an dem tag als ich ihn zum
ersten mal gesehen habe war ich muss
meiner familie auf ein dorf ist
[Musik]
so bricht dort in der nähe ist auch ein
spielplatz plötzlich kam eine toxische
angerannt sagte da ist ein typ der zeit
sein ich bin sofort dahin auf die
spielplatz ist ein häuschen aussehen wie
ich dabei christian brückner war ihr
haus mit heruntergelassenen hosen und
habe meine tochter an geschaut und hat
gesagt hey du wie ist dein name
corrado daraufhin habe die polizei
angerufen die auch sofort cabrio wie sie
vehement auf google sagt cent und wie
der junge da war total betrunken
vielleicht waren auch andere toben
er saß und dem haus und hat irgendwie
kinderhandel stock
sowie diverse soll erst heute wissen sie
wer der mann ist
wann haben sie sich das
blatt und die sonne als ich den im
fernsehen gesehen habe habe ich zu
meinem mann gesagt das ist doch der typ
der damals unsere tochter belästigt im
weg steht
er hat gesagt das ist doch quatsch drei
tage später am stand ein freund
angerufen der damals auch dabei war und
hat gesagt
siehst du nicht was gerade im fernsehen
bbc
das ist doch der chip von spielt meist
ich bin sofort in tränen ausgebrochen im
dachte das hätte auch meine tochter sein
wo der täter geraten jetzt viele befehle
die frau ist den tränen nahe feldhaus
beendet das gespräch ja ist im grunde
der erste mensch mit dem ich gesprochen
habe der ein opfer des verdächtigen im
fall maddie mccann ist also jemand der
direkt davon betroffen ist von einer tat
begangen hat
diese festnahme bringt immer mehr dinge
zum vorschein die ein klares bild von
christian bezeichnen weit braucht kai
feldhaus nicht reisen um weitere infos
über den neuen verdächtigen im fall
maddie zu erfahren alles nahm hier in
der algarve und seinen anfang bei dem
versuch dem verdächtigen christian b ein
bisschen näher zu kommen und zu
verstehen versuche ich jetzt mal
chronologisch vorzugehen und wir sind
auf dieser kleinen zeitreise durch sein
leben jetzt mitte der 90er jahre er ist
gerade vor einer haftstrafe in würzburg
getürmt erstmals an die algarve nimmt
einen job als kellner an in lagos das
hier war die
tabellen der die lage
hier hat christian wie in den 90er
jahren als kind er arbeitet sich hier
ein bisschen kohle zu verdienen und
irgendwo im hinterland dem häuschen zu
beziehen
der bild-reporter läuft die kleinen
gassen entlang sucht hier und da das
gespräch oft trifft auf ganz klare
ablehnung niemand möchte über dieses
thema sprechen das ist doch alles schon
so lange her
mit leuten über das thema zu reden weil
es einfach 14 jahre so breit getreten
worden ist
und nicht nur hier in portugal oder in
großbritannien dem heimatland von maddie
mccann auch in der bild-redaktion in
berlin muss immer wieder ausgelotet
werden was berichtenswert ist und was
nicht eine so große dimension wie sie
dieser fall hat und die länge über die
er sich jetzt erstreckt sie führt
natürlich auch dazu das ist sehr sehr
viele menschen gibt die sich berufen
fühlen was dazu zu sagen die diesen fall
zu ihrem hobby gemacht haben
unaufgefordert und das dann auch gerne
medien und ermittler mitteilen die große
kunst in der berichterstattung über den
fall maddie mccann ist den unfug von den
fundierten
grundlagen zu unterscheiden und das ist
manchmal wirklich schwierig weil
natürlich auch leute hier im haus sehen
und lesen was die kollegen in england
schreiben und dann sagen das müssen wir
auch machen und ich hoffe dann immer
hinterher und sammle das alles wieder
ein sagt leute ganz im ernst wollt ihr
wirklich über ein hellseher berichten
der weiß wo mehr dem erkennt verscharrt
ist und ich glaube eben so viele
geschichten wie ich über diesen fall
geschrieben habe ebenso viele
geschichten habe ich im grunde auch
verhindert indem ich gesagt eher blass
und das nicht machen da es mit dem
hellseher
der reporter muss ein wenig grinsen als
er daran denkt etwas später wieder im
gut klimatisierten auto telefoniert kai
feldhaus mit einer ehemaligen bekannten
von christian b der das haus gehört in
dem der heutige hauptverdächtige im fall
maddie lange zeit wohnte sie ist
ziemlich genervt bleibt aber in der
leitung
eine sehr interessante informationen aus
dem gespräch mit der bekannten von
christian w herausgekommen ist dass
christian b zwei seiten hatte auf der
einen seite ganz liebenswerte
umgänglicher höflicher mensch gewesen
sein der sehr gute tieren konnte mit
seinem hund bei denen war der hund total
bezogen der war immer dann wenn er
betrunken war zitat zum totalen
arschloch wurde also sagt dann hat er
sich nicht mehr im griff dann ist der
totale rolle gefallen das ist ja
aggressiven ausfallend geworden
als sie ihn kennenlernte und 195 da
wusste sie wohl dass er probleme mit der
justiz hatte aber dass ihm eine strafe
wegen kindesmissbrauchs blühte das hat
er da wo ich mal verschwiegen ich habe
sie gefragt sich vorstellen kann dass
jemand wie christian e eine solche tat
begeht sein kind entführen und ermorden
so wie sie ihn kennengelernt hat in der
nüchtern war sei das vollkommen
undenkbar
aber nach allem was sie mittlerweile
erfahren hat und es ist offenbar auch
schon bka vernommen worden könnte sie
sich durchaus vorstellen dass er dort
einsteigen wollte um etwas zu klauen
also zitat einbruch zu machen und dann
ihm dabei das kind unter kam und das hat
dann vielleicht geschrieben oder gestört
oder hat die gelegenheit genutzt sagt
sie das kannst du bei dem es
mittlerweile weiß
dass christian b aus würzburg abgehauen
ist um nicht in den knast zu wandern das
weiß kai feldhaus schon lange er kann
sich noch gut an das gespräch mit einer
bekannten von christian beetz familie
aus kindertagen erinnern seinerzeit
besuchte der reporter das geburtshaus
von christian b eine kleine wohnung über
einer dorfkneipe
dettelbach das ist eine kleine gemeinde
bei würzburg in franken die gaststätte
scharfes eck wo die ganze geschichte
ihren anfang genommen hat denn hier in
der wohnung oben drüber
lebte ende der 70er jahre die leibliche
mutter von christian brückner sie
verkehrt in dieser kneipe die auch
regelmäßig aufgesucht wurde von
kleinkriminellen aus der gegend und
bekam zwei söhne diese söhne wurden ihre
verschiedenen gründen vom jugendamt
weggenommen christian und sein bruder
kamen dann zur pflegefamilie und zur
pflege und später zur adoption damals
trifft kai feldhaus die ehemalige
freundin der familie brückner auf einem
feldweg mitten im nirgendwo sie will
nicht erkannt und vor allem nicht mit
dem fall maddie in verbindung gebracht
werden also wo ich kennengelernt habe
ganz normale liebenswerte kinder wie
viele also noch einmal liegt das waren
herr brückner und frau brücken und wie
viele kinder das waren drei kinder
großer und die zwei kleinen zuletzte zu
kommen christian und wenn sie an ihn
zurückdenken als sie damals in den 80ern
viel kontakt mit der familie hatten
welche szene kommt in der besonders in
den kopf das war schon im schulalter der
hat an hausaufgaben gemacht oder gemalt
irgendwas wollte was fragen hat sondern
auch so angeschrien und hatten mit den
kopf voll von ihnen am tisch geknallt
der wusste gar nicht was los war der
junge sie haben erzählt
jeden hund jahren wenn sie den hund
angepackt haben oder irgendwas nahm die
schimpfen
der hund war vorher da darf es war ein
und alles
das heißt der und wurde besser behandelt
als habe ich immer gedacht ja und jetzt
etliche will die kinder ja ich denke
wenn wir versuchen vollumfänglich zu
erklären wer der mann ist der maddie
mccann entführt und ermordet haben soll
dann müssen wir das ganze bild sehen
dann müssen wir auch gucken wie war das
kind wie war das jugendlicher was ist
denn passiert was hat der gemacht dass
der so in so eine kriminelle ecke
abgedriftet ist
das heißt das elternhaus war nicht liebe
nein das war nicht liebe vor das war
ziemlich kalt und ich dachte das geht
denen nur um das geld und das kommen wir
besonders hoch musste bei uns zu besuch
war und er hat ein gesetz kann
wahrscheinlich weil er angst hatte dann
sind sie ins wohnzimmer wo man sagt er
warum ist die hose nass wir waren alles
rum stand hat in die hose bis nun der
hatten gerade raus und hatten
ausgepeitscht ja wohl der weihnachtsmann
kriegst du noch einmal welche ich bin
der zwischen nach hat er gesagt
gewechselt kriegst du auch noch eine und
sie war der bald stand regungslos und
dann habe ich ja gesagt die werden das
jugendamt man sagen der große oder
wasser hat sie ganz stolz gesagt die
sind so getrennt
ist das wahr ist gelaufen die verraten
mich nicht das alles klingt nach einer
sehr üblen kindheit ohne liebe ohne
respekt und nähe die brüder und
christian werden auffällig wissen sie
denn aus dem dorf möglicherweise was man
sich da erzählt über die über die brüder
die prüferische kriminell waren das
alles angestellt haben zum beispiel
busse aufgeschlitzte sitze und so die
haben mein auto geklaut die haben weil
banker aufgeschlitzt im bus sie haben
strohballen aufgeschlitzt also
lausbubenstreiche bis hin zu
sachbeschädigungen und das geht dann
aber nahtlos über
1993 gab es dann die erste verurteilung
wegen diebstahls in drei fällen acht
monate auf bewährung für christian b ein
jahr später 1994 dann die erste anklage
wegen sexuellen missbrauchs
entblößen vor einem kind dafür gab es
zwei jahre jugendstrafe auf bewährung
kurz danach ist christian b abgehauen
nach portugal
ist ein rückzugsort für viele für
aussteiger und für hippies aber auch
viele kleinkriminelle
ich habe die telefonnummer von einem
deutschen der christian brückner an der
algarve kennengelernt hat damit ihm
ziemlich viel zeit verbracht hat den
versuche ich jetzt mal anzurufen aber
schon festgestellt dass viele leute kein
großes bedürfnis mehr haben sich in
dieser sache öffentlich zu äußern
überhaupt zu häusern bin schon froh ganz
ehrlich
mein name ist kai feldhaus ich bin
reporter von bild in berlin ich grüße
sie
ich bin an der algarve unterwegs und
recherchiere an einem größeren stück zum
verschwinden von maddie mccann und zu
christian brückner kann sie den
christian brückner
wie haben sie den denn so erlebt also
was waren das für ein typ ich kann gar
nicht richtig greifen
wissen sie sonst irgendwas über den wo
der abgeblieben ist das thema zwischen
deutschland und
es gibt drei leute die mit christian b
im tatzeitraum richtig viel zu tun haben
die mit ihm krumme dinger gedreht haben
die mit dem diesel geklaut haben oder
solarpaneele diese drei könnten dazu
beitragen das rätsel zu lösen
das ist einmal michael t mit dem er
gemeinsam clusters der ist in österreich
abgetaucht
dann ist das manfred es der dritte das
ist helge b der nämlich hat diese ganzen
ermittlungen ausgelöst indem er der
polizei gesagt hat der brückner hat mir
die tat dem mord an maddie mccann
2008 gestanden
er hat auch schon mal gesagt in anderem
zusammenhang dass es viele menschen gibt
die wissen was die mehr kennen passiert
ist nämlich brückner michael t manfred s
und ihn selbst der mit vom bka
abgeschirmt mal ein wichtiger zeuge ist
lebt zurückgezogen irgendwann mittelmeer
und hat kein interesse mit der presse zu
sprechen immerhin hat er mir eine
sprachnachricht geschickt
zu kontaktieren die pläne haben
eigentlich in der presse
der reporter legt das telefon in die
mittelkonsole des mietwagens und lässt
die heiße luft durch die offenen fenster
einströmen er muss zurück nach
deutschland und mit den alten kumpels
von christian besprechen und er muss den
profi axel petermann noch mal treffen
diese bandbreite von delikten von
drogenhandel über diebstahl bis zu
sexuellem missbrauch von kindern und
vergewaltigung ist das ein tat verhalten
dass ihnen in ihrer karriere auch
häufiger unter gekommen ist oder das ist
sehr ungewöhnlich der ex ermittler autor
und profiler streicht sich über den
weißen schnauzbart ja es sind zwar
ungewöhnlich ist sagt so ist mich als
würde er so eine antisoziale
persönlichkeit zeigen nicht den
eigentlich alles ist keine grenzen
respektiert der einfach das tut was man
ihn ja in dem moment angenehm ist oder
was was wir mal was richtig ist dass ein
tat verhalten das in ihrer karriere auch
häufiger unter gekommen ist das ist sehr
ungewöhnlich es ist schon sehr
ungewöhnlich natürlich gibt es täter die
missbrauchten die töten aber die
wenigsten
dokumentieren ist das sind eben mit
souvenirs oder ideen die man von den
taten mitnimmt um sie denn dann später
für sich wenn man sich alleine fühlt
dann wieder aufzuarbeiten und das dort
wieder einzutauchen in das fast leid
getan
christian b hat die tat die ihnen im
knast in deutschland brachte auf video
dokumentiert die vergewaltigung einer
älteren us-amerikanerin erfahren hat das
bild reporter kai feldhaus von manfred
es einem der alten bekannten von
christian b als freunde würde man sie
nicht bezeichnen wie der reporter bei
einem kneipen treffen mit dem verlebt
wirkenden und kettenrauchenden ex
aussteiger verstellt
manfred seifert zu treffen er ist einer
der wichtigsten weggefährten von
christian brückner in seiner zeit an der
algarve ich hoffe dass der arzt hat mir
ein bisschen was erzählen kann darüber
wie der brücke so ist und auch was da
los war in der zeit als man ihm erkennt
verschwand grundsätzlich ist manfred
seifert recht mitteilungsbedürftig er
hat schon mehrere interviews gegeben
wenn man ihnen was fragt dann sagt doch
was dazu aber es war jetzt eine weile
nicht ganz leicht ihn zu erreichen wie
es jetzt gelungen in den lüdenscheid
ausfindig zu machen verschlungene pfade
haben ihn hierher geführt und jetzt hat
er sich aber zu einem interview bereit
erklärt
wann haben sie das letzte mal kontakt zu
christian wittmann das letzte mal habe
ich blut naja wir aus dem gefängnis
gekommen ist war habe ich ihn dann im
spanien wieder getroffen auf den trägen
festival da war ich habe wegen festival
noch andere leute auch aber eben
und da kam dann der spezi da lang
gelaufen auf dem platz wieder mit sohn
jungmädel dabei 15 recht sehen und haben
sich damit dem unterhalten ich bin ich
habe gesehen wird er gott weg ich bin
gleich erklären ich habe den immer
gefressen immer gefragt das hat nicht
gepasst an den typen die ganze art wie
er ist das ganze wesen ist für mich
schon immer krank gewesen
brolin
wahnvorstellung obwohl sind das wirklich
vorstellbar
und ziemlich aggressiv warum wir dann
gegenüber weil er wohl gemerkt hat dass
ich da nicht auf seiner wellenlänge
fahre oder straftaten verbrechen mein
thema also einbrüche diebstähle jahr so
kleinkram was wir also finanziellen 15
jahre
die wilmar geholt oder sowas und dadurch
kann der dann natürlich auch auf die
idee mit solarpanelen wir haben eine
hohe
paneele holen ist letztlich der
diebstahl von solartechnik im großen
maßstab kleinere einbrüche fahrzeug und
treibstoff diebstahl werden von manfred
es gar nicht groß mitgezählt peanuts
kann man einzelne aktuellen verurteilung
der frist am rücken da sitzt im knast
was haben sie damit zu tun aber weil wir
das video mal gefunden haben wo die
vergewaltigung drauf das haben wir mal
einen sein haus und dabei ein gefängnis
da sind wir wieder mal die wir holen
aber was war dachte da ist noch live und
dann haben wir dringend türen auf alles
auf haus durchsucht gewesen schon alles
ich dachte erst polizei habe schon
gekriegt aber
auch noch alles rum weisung wertvolle
gegenstände liegen auf der erde laden
alles weiß heute weiß ich nicht warum
dass die polizei neben das alles mit
oder so normalerweise polizei
kleine kassen wollen und bereit ist klar
ich habe die pistole gefunden habe mir
die auch ein stück weit theorie kann die
offerten wohl die habe ich später dann
der kirche mission in sonntag klar
denken dass ich nicht schon geschehen
wird
was man auf diesen videos zu sehen die
videos haben wir uns später angeguckt
dagegen die meinung heute außenanlage er
gesagt haben sie gelesen ich habe sie
auf diesen kleinen winter gesehen habe
dass ohne erinnerung und noch mehr leute
gesehen woher das mädchen das auf dem
video war wie er ist wo ist da schmeiß
weg die scheiße union kümmert sich dann
nicht darum
so der
wirt ingo im ort aber die hat das
gesehen das video also es war zweifellos
der vergewaltigung
frei wenige fühlen alles und das war
auch einwandfrei
christian b6 kumpane haben am ende dafür
gesorgt dass die videos bei der polizei
landen und den vergewaltiger hinter
gitter bringen das geht auch durch die
medien
wir wollen einmal schauen auf die
strafakte des tatverdächtigen christian
b seine verbrecherkarriere begann vor 28
jahren seine erste aktenkundige tat ein
einbruch scheint inrix krimineller zu
sein schwerpunkte liegen allerdings
immer weise zwei straftaten bei
drogenhandel auch bei herstellung von
drogen und einbruchsdiebstahl erscheint
also richtig seinen lebensunterhalt
bestritten zu haben und auf der anderen
seite immer wieder auch diese
sexualstraftaten deswegen momentan sitzt
und diese tat ihm da vorgeworfen wird
ist aus dem jahre 2005 auch an der
algarve da handelt sich aber um eine
ältere dame und er hat ja auch eine 72
jährige frau vergewaltigt sollen tat
auch gefilmt haben so ist man ihm auf
die schliche gekommen
christian besitzt also seine haftstrafe
ab und führt bis juni 2020 in der
justizvollzugsanstalt das leben eines
relativ normalen insassen als aber
bekannt wird dass er nun verdächtigt ist
maddie mccann getötet zu haben verändert
sich alles er sitzt mittlerweile 23
stunden am tag in einer einzelzelle das
heißt er hat keinerlei sozialkontakte
meer und mindestens sechs jahre würde
noch hinter gittern sein
mit der gebotenen sorgfalt wird nun im
neuen verfahren gegen ihn ermittelt aber
bislang wurde noch keine anklage erhoben
kai feldhaus befragt dazu den
staatsanwalt heinz christian wolters in
braunschweig im juni 2020 ist dieser an
die öffentlichkeit getreten und sagte
für alle vollkommen überraschend wir
haben hier in braunschweig einen mann
von dem wir sicher sind dass er maddie
mccann entführt und getötet hat das kam
damals aus sehr heiterem himmel niemand
hat mit so etwas gerechnet
das schlug wellen die rund um die welt
jagten
[Musik]
eindeutige worte die im falle der 2007
verschwundenen maddie mccann so noch nie
gefallen sind
hauptverdächtiger ist der 43 jährige
christian b der derzeit in haft sitzt
braunschweig
250.000 einwohner und bekannt für
jägermeister also man hätte ja gedacht
die ermittlung spielen in lissabon oder
meinetwegen in london
aber in braunschweig
mitten in der tiefsten deutschen provinz
hier wird gegen christian ruck ermittelt
hier wurde er zuletzt verurteilt und
hier würde wenn es soweit kommt auch ein
strafverfahren in sachen mit dem
erkennen stattfinden
ich erhoffe mir von diesem besuch bei
hans christian wollte dass er mir ganz
klar sagt christian brückner ist unser
mann und deshalb sind wir uns so sicher
er wollte das was wird christian beeck
konkret vorgeworfen christel wird
vorgeworfen 2007 in praia da luz
schnelle mccann getötet zu haben warum
sind sie so sicher dass sie den
richtigen haben dass sie den mann haben
der maddie mccann ermordet hat ich kann
leider im moment nicht ausführen welche
beweise wir tatsächlich haben die für
christian b als täter sprechen aber aus
unserer sicht sind sie ebenso groß genug
dass wir uns auch letztes jahr im
entschlossen haben diesen verdacht
öffentlich zu machen sie haben beweise
erwähnt die vorliegen was genau hat es
damit auf sich das einzige indiz was mir
auch bekannt gegeben haben dass dieser
funktion treffer aus praia da luz
außerdem werden hinweise zu zwei
portugiesischen mobilfunknummern gesucht
die zur tatrelevanten zeit im bereich
von dreyer da luz genutzt wurden wir
ordnen ihm eine telefonnummer zu die
tatsächlich in diesen in dieser
datensammlung enthalten war aus dem wir
ja schließen dass sich christian behl
tatsächlich zur tatzeit am tatort
gefunden hat das große rätsel ist die
partner nummer da suchen wir leider nach
wie vor
aber es genügt nicht um ihn anzuklagen
und zu ermittlungen laufen ja noch und
es macht aus meiner sicht keinen sinn
bevor man das ergebnis dieser
ermittlungen hat sich mit dem gedanken
zu tragen können wir eine anklage
erheben oder können wir das nicht
christian besitzt die nächsten jahre in
haft und wie es aussieht das heißt da
rennt uns nicht weg wenn wir auf ihn
zugreifen wollen haben wir ihn verfügbar
da wenn wir sozusagen mit unseren
ermittlungen wirklich abschluss sind
dann wenn wir alles auf den tisch legen
und dann werden wir schauen haben wir
diesen reifen tatverdacht oder nicht
wenn wir ein haben
bild reporter kai feldhaus lehnt sich
zurück und denkt wieder an das hotel
lobby gespräch mit dem charismatischen
ex ermittler konsole amaral in lissabon
wenn der deutsche staatsanwalt die
portugiesischen akten noch nicht gelesen
hat was er bestimmt nicht hat sind
tausende von seiten dann sollte er es
tun und gut aufpassen es gab in der
portugiesischen untersuchung nichts das
auf eine entführung hin deutete im
gegenteil es ist eigentlich unmöglich
dass eine entführung stattgefunden hat
christian b hat mit dem verschwinden von
maddie mccann nichts zu tun das steht in
den portugiesischen akten
sollte lieber mal geklärt werden warum
hier eine entführung simuliert wurde man
kann christian b nicht einfach die nähe
des ocean clubs platzieren und das ihm
dann anhängen selbst wenn es sein handy
war die funkzelle ist groß
dass er dort war das eher ein dieb ist
der sogar über kindesmissbrauch
diebstähle oder mordfälle schrieb dass
er das abnormale leben eines
psychopathen führte das ist alles kein
beweis dafür dass er für die tat
verantwortlich ist erst einmal muss
bewiesen werden dass es eine entführung
gegeben
[Musik]
die leute sagen was für einen monster
dieser christian b ist es würde mich
nicht überraschen wenn eines tag ist ein
foto auftauchen würde welcher art auch
immer genauso wie im letzten verfahren
wo plötzlich ein haar aufgetaucht ist
da die sache mit dem h aber dazu später
der staatsanwalt kontert gleich als der
reporter von amaral erzählt weiß nicht
auf welcher grundlage er amaral seine
aussagen trifft wir haben den
tatverdacht gegen christian b und im
gegensatz zu herrn amerell sehen wir die
eltern ausschließlich als zeugen die mit
der tat tatsächlich nichts zu tun aber
dann räumt auch er ein natürlich sind
wir auf das angewiesen was die
portugiesen
2007 unmittelbar nach der tat an
spurensicherung arbeit beispielsweise
betrieben haben und es gab natürlich
dann auch weitergehende ermittlungen der
britischen behörden die wir natürlich
auch in unserer ermittlungen mit
einfließen lassen also wenn man so will
ist das eine multinationale ermittlungen
die wir hier führen natürlich unter
regie des bundeskriminalamtes und sich
ist es aber auch so dass uns die meinung
eines portugiesisch ex polizisten wenig
interessiert wir gehen davon aus dass
ihm unsere akten nicht vorlegen und
deshalb sind auch seine
schlussfolgerungen für uns
okay wieder zurück nach berlin bild
reporter kai feldhaus hat nach vielen
versuchen der kontaktaufnahme ein
schreiben erhalten über das er mit
profiler axel petermann sprechen will
nachdem es zunächst hieß christian
brüggmann werde sich öffentlich äußern
denn nun aus der haft einen brief
geschrieben eine pressemitteilung wie er
das nennt was verrät dieser brief über
ihn
also ich bin überrascht gewesen als sich
dieses schreibens harvey ordentlich das
abgefasst ist als hätte jemand bald mit
einer schablone geschrieben ich bin auch
das überrascht wie wenig fehler er
gemacht hat und er sagt kampf klar ich
bin das nicht gewesen es gibt keine
beweise und diejenigen die das zu
verantworten haben sollten und dafür für
ihr verhalten auch belangt werden
glauben sie dass es clever war diesen
brief zu schreiben er wird sicherlich
der meinung sein die sammeln jetzt alles
was sie finden können um mich mit
weiteren straftaten und straße zu
übernehmen vielleicht hilft mir also ein
appell in der öffentlichkeit sicher auch
zu überlegen muss das denn alle stimmen
was mir vorgeworfen wird
die wenigen lichter im axel springer
gebäude in den späten abendstunden
zeigen dass für die meisten journalisten
der arbeitstag zu ende geht kai feldhaus
sitzt erschöpft von den letzten tagen in
der kleinen sofa ecke seines büros der
lauwarme instant kaffee ist so lala aber
was soll's erst durch die e mails auf
seinem iphone
natürlich habe ich in den vergangenen 14
jahren immer mal wieder kontakt zur kate
and gerry mccann gesucht zum erwins
eltern von dem ich wissen wollte wie sie
zum stand der ermittlungen stehen auch
in der aktuellen recherche habe ich sie
kontaktiert habe ich eine e mail
geschrieben und sie um eine
stellungnahme gebeten immerhin gibt es
plötzlich einen verdächtigen aber auch
immer noch menschen wie goncalo amaral
die sie der tat bezichtigt
ich habe eine antwort bekommen auf meine
e-mail
denke ja noch nie interviews an lästerte
durch so bei law enforcement agencies
er bedankt sich für die anfrage gesagt
aber ganz klar dass die eltern derzeit
keine interviews geben solange die
ermittlungsbehörden ihnen das nicht
empfehlen zwei termine hat der reporter
noch auf seiner liste aber jetzt muss er
erst einmal schlafen der kaffee hilft
sowieso kein stück
in hamburg trifft kai feldhaus auf den
verteidiger von christian b auf dem dach
eines geschäftshauses begrüßte
erstaunlich junge anwalt friedrich
fischer den bild-reporter eher
hanseatisch unterkühlten
über einem jahr wird nun öffentlich
gegen christian brücken ermittelt sie
sind wahrscheinlich der einzige mensch
der regelmäßig kontakt zu ihnen hat wie
geht es ihnen denn im gefängnis das
würde frage also er sitzt für eine
straftat mehrere jahre in haft von der
er behauptet diese nicht begangen zu
haben und es an einer weltweiten
vorstandes kampagne ausgesetzt also wie
soll es ihm da gehen haben sie als
verteidiger das gefühl das ist eine
öffentliche vorverurteilung ihres
mandanten die vorverurteilung liegt auf
der hand
die medien die boulevardpresse dazu
zähle ich auch ihr haus hat seit einem
jahr nichts besseres zu tun als diese
causa maddie und die personen christian
brückner immer wieder in den fokus zu
rücken angefeuert von einem
pressesprecher der staatsanwaltschaft
braunschweig
der auch jedes medium sucht und
kontinuierlich gebetsmühlenartig runter
betet wir sind davon überzeugt brückner
hat mehdi getötet eine haftstrafe sitz
der aktuell noch ab die sieben jahre für
die vergewaltigung einer 72 jährigen
amerikanerin in praia da luz sie waren
in dem verfahren noch nicht sein
verteidiger ist er da vernünftig
verteidigt worden in diesem prozess
meinen augen ganz klares nein
das verfahren hat insgesamt drei tage
gedauert
der komplexität ist das in meinen augen
zu kurz die verteidigung hat damals
wesentliche aspekte nicht thematisiert
hat auf beweisanträge verzichtet die
zwingend zu stellen gewesen wären weil
man davon ausgehen dass wird ein
glasklarer freispruch ich vermute dass
seine strategie dahinter steckt die
staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig mit den
gedanken haben die kammer wäre einfacher
davon zu überzeugen dass herr brückner
ein kleines mädchen entführt und getötet
hat wenn er schon vorbestraft ist für so
ein grausames sexualverbrechen welches
schwächen weiß aus ihrer sicht das
modell ist 2009 10 in braunschweig
gefällt wurde auch das gab es zwei
zeugenaussagen die letztendlich
maßgeblich für die beurteilung waren
diese zeugen halte ich für absolut
unglaubwürdig und unseriös man hat ein
haar gefunden welches beim mandanten
zugeordnet wurde auch das kann man
berechtigterweise an zweifel und an oral
der zum beginn der ermittlungen im fall
maddie mccann geführt hat der nannte
christian brückner im gespräch mit uns
den ich zitiere das perfekten
verdächtigen weil auf ihnen einfach
alles passe was die polizei brauche um
ein und irgendjemand zu finden und
imitat anzuhängen teilen sie diese
ansicht das trifft mir dann schon etwas
weit in den bereich
verschwörungstheorien ab und das ist
nicht mal mit ihr ich habe mich an
fakten zu orientieren
ich habe herrn brückner zu verteidigen
und auch nicht diesen fall maddie
aufzuklären was also viele leute seit
einiger zeit denken dass wieder die
sache mit dem haar und die unseriösen
zeugen sind manfred es der verlebte
aussteiger und kleinkriminelle sowie
helge b der zeuge geschützt irgendwo im
mittelmeerraum lebt war der
vergewaltigungs-prozess gegen christian
b schon so wirklich wie die
anschuldigungen die ihm heute in bezug
auf den fall maddie gemacht werden der
vorerst letzte termin wartet
dr nicole von wurmb schwarz sie ist
privatdozentin und forensische genetik
das heißt sie ist so eine art detektiv
für tatorte sie trägt eine große brille
dahinter wache schlaue augen frau doktor
von wohnungsmarkt wie genau helfen sie
in diesem labor im mittlern gericht
polizei und staatsanwälten kriminalfälle
zu lösen man untersucht genetische
merkmale die dieses individuelle
merkmals muster machen was eben die
leute 32 als genetischer fingerabdruck
kennen das sind 16 datenbanksysteme so
nennen wir die auch weil die hat in
diese datenbank rein kommt und wenn sie
sechzehn datenbanksysteme zu einer
schuhe passen dann rechnen wir das und
dann kann man sagen mit welcher
wahrscheinlichkeit dieses spur
tatsächlich zu dem möglichen spuren ich
würde mit ihnen gerne reden über das
urteil gegen christian brückner im
vergewaltigungs-prozess 2009 10
er ist verurteilt worden maßgeblich weil
man eine h dass ihnen zugeordnet wurde
am tatort gefunden hat man hat bis auf
dieses einer keine weitere dna des
angeklagten
gefunden ist das bei dem
tat ablauf der geschildert wurde
realistisch ist das zu erwarten dass man
dann nur ein haar fingen sie dürfen
natürlich niemals nie sagen und selbst
wenn sie jetzt sagen sie kennen den
tatablauf waren sie natürlich nicht
dabei und es ist schon erstaunlich wenn
man in solchen fällen sehr sehr wenig
der nach findet
sie kennen das dna gutachten auf dessen
basis christian brückner verurteilt
wurde wenn sie die gutachter in diesem
prozess gewesen wären hätten sie dem
angeklagten auf basis der datenlage
dieses hart zugeordnet oder nicht hätte
ich nicht gemacht in dem fall war das so
wir haben 16 datenbanksysteme untersucht
also das absolut mögliche was man machen
muss und haben aber an diesem jahr kein
vollständiges genetisches profil
gefunden sondern nur zehn merkmale die
vollständig typisiert waren und was der
gutachter dann gemacht hat in dem
gutachten das war dass er dann einfach
nur die zehen betrachtet hat und mit den
zehen passenden merkmalen eine
biostatistik durchgeführt hat und dann
gesagt hat diese kombination dieser 10
gehen orte zusammen mit diesen merkmalen
kommt nur mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit
von irgendwas über 2 300 milliarden mal
vor also ist es mit einem sicherheit
grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit davon
auszugehen dass dieses h dem
tatverdächtigen gehört wo steht der fall
heute die ermittlungen in braunschweig
werden wohl weiter laufen jetzt wird
seit gut einem jahr ermittelt warum ist
noch keine anklage erhoben worden
weil unsere ermittlungen tatsächlich im
moment nicht zu ende sind christian
besitzt die nächsten jahre in haft so
wie es aussieht das heißt er rennt uns
nicht weg wenn wir auf ihn zugreifen
wollen haben wir ihn verfügbar da wir
können also uns die zeit nehmen die wir
brauchen wir können wirklich alles
ermitteln und das soll dann sozusagen
auch das bestmögliche ergebnis sein und
wenn wir sozusagen mit unseren
ermittlungen wirklich am abschluss sind
dann wenn wir alles auf den tisch legen
und dann werden wir schauen haben wir
den reifen den tatverdacht oder nicht
kai feldhaus wird wohl noch viele titel
zum fall maddie schreiben müssen der
fall ist noch lange nicht vorbei dem
reporter scheint es nur so dass über die
jahre die medialen kämpfe und der zwist
unter den ermittlern immer weiter
zugenommen hat er kann nur hoffen dass
diese zwist produktiv ist und man dies
eltern endlich gewissheit erlangen
werden wer ihre tochter aus dem leben
gerissen hat ob sie vielleicht sogar
noch lebt oder ihr dasein am sonnigen
strand von playa de los ein jähes ende
fand dann denkt kai feldhaus zurück an
seinen aufenthalt in dem ferienort den
blick über die nächtlich beleuchtete
appartement anlage mit ihren palmen die
sich im lauen abend wind der algarve
wiegen
[Musik]
wenn man sich dann wieder ins gedächtnis
was hier passiert ist dann
ein bisschen anders
an dieser stelle möchte ich wieder
einmal danke sagen dass er dabei war
mein name ist sky dumont und ich freue
mich wenn ihr auch beim nächsten mal
zuhört bei tatort deutschland
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus dem wakeboard studios
projektleitung simone terbrack
produktion fabian schaeffler drehbuch
lutz neumann
redaktion bild kai feldhaus und stefan
netze bald
ist das meta was die zukunft des
internets braucht mein handy einen für
ihren scanner
was bedeutet es wenn microsoft stück für
stück große spiele entwickler aufkauft
und warum ist mein wlan immer so laut
die tech branche bewegt sich wahnsinnig
schnell und unser podcast hilft euch
nicht den kopf zu verlieren
mit den tech freak bleibt ihr immer
bestens informiert
vertreiben jeden freitag auf bild.de und
überall wo es gute podcasts gibt
[Musik]